hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Fatal Frame 2 everybody
has been demanding this game and for
good reason it is one of the
highest-rated horror games of all time
made for the ps2 and Xbox era of gaming
now when I'm going to be playing this
game I originally wanted to play on the
original Xbox and ps2 version of it
however the only copy that I had access
to was actually not working so I am
maybe we would always be together that
depends on a lot of circumstances
oh no oh you're talking to a pod doctor
who needs to clear all the cream yeah
I'll be gone soon why is your leg okay
does it hurt
it does a lot but I'm fine ma'am
yes never mind
Maya about that time back then oh she's
gone no no don't chase the red butterfly
the crimson the crimson butterfly is the
name of the game
alright then this game is off to a bit
of a bang there was a lot of information
to take in all at once basically these
two are sisters and I don't know what it
is about watching two japanese
schoolgirls interacting with giant dead
doll eyes but it's kind of creepy for
some reason or another it's like when
the shining had those two little girls
in the hallway one of the scariest
moments in all of movie cinema and is
very parody but either way as I was
saying before I would have loved to play
this in the original incarnation that it
was meant to be played in and
unfortunately I am emulating the game
now what that means is I've tweaked it
very much to try to emulate it in the
best way possible but because it is an
emulation that means there might be some
quirkiness to it there might be a few
bugs here and there there might be some
glitches here there there might see be
some audio issues that I was trying to
hammer out now I've loaded up the game
but I was skipping that initial cutscene
so I actually had not seen that before
and I don't know a damn thing about this
game
Mayu other than I'm looking for a girl
named Maya who's more likely my sister
than anybody else and it seemed to be
some lights at the top of this hill okay
this is about the extent of which I've
tested it before so I don't know if
they're going to be as many bugs as I
hope there aren't going to be if that
hello creepy lady I'm doing I bet you're
fun
was that a crimson butterfly I don't
know you wandered here I'm assuming you
live nearby why do you keep asking me
questions Marla she's possessed
musk Garrett can when you start saying
creepy stuff like that that really leads
me to believe oh there's the tiny fatal
frame to crimson butterfly everybody
hope you're ready for an adventure
disappeared during a festival people who
get lost in the woods who trapped by the
village that place well I mean you're
the one who initially said as soon as we
walked up to this place the lost village
in a very creepy way and might I add
butterflies just shot out of your ass
for no reason at all so I'm gonna go
under the assumption that this is
probably that it said chapter one last
village so here we go okay oh sorry
excuse me pardon me Kimmy I needed to
walk here sorry is your leg hurt hi
father guys piers excuse me sorry okay
so anyway as I was saying there's us
here are they all ghosts do I need to
collect some ghost souls with a camera
or something so anyway as I was trying
to say there are a lot of cutscenes in
these types of games I've actually not
played that many Japanese horror games
but I am really really really thoroughly
excited to play this particular game
because I have heard so much stuff about
it and it may be that it's hyped up but
also I would like to be led to believe
that there aren't as many idiots on the
internet as people think there are and
that people who review things actually
might be able to do something this looks
important oh I didn't even need to touch
it there's something on the ground black
bag there are several pieces of paper
and a photo inside news clipping news
clipping from a year ago the headline
reads Geological Survey are missing with
the start of construction for all
gods-damned approaching Misumi Malky
uramaki Mira sorry I'm terribly sorry if
I butchered names a geological surveyor
dispatched the area has gone missing mr.
Malcolm aura went to the area to
investigate the site that would be
submerged once the dam was built but
hasn't been heard from for five
it's probably bad follow-up search for
Masumi machi mera
the surveyor missing since the fourth
this month came to a close he'd been
helping to conduct a Geological Survey
as of yesterday he has been missing for
10 days wait it came to a close you just
gave up okay all right then
photo of a couple in your life I don't
know just you and me for now and a whole
bunch of ghosts on best thing that been
guessing guessing I'm having trouble
talking at the moment just cuz I'm so
damn excited to play this game and I
didn't think about it I actually have
played some Japanese Sal horror games
before yeah my little run or something
okay hi hey welcome to the party what oh
she just disappeared into a wall didn't
she pretty sure that's what happened
because I have played Japanese style
horror games before in the RPG horror
maker games now thatin does not mean
that those are authentic to the form of
what this can be but that doesn't mean
that they don't tell you it's not her
hand it's like Jurassic Park what did
you say to me
Meah
somebody pick up the phone cuz I called
it okay hi I know you're gonna just cost
by that one
you ain't gonna put a ghost in the
window and just pretend it never
happened okay I guess we're just gonna
pretend it never happened
huh get out of the house somewhere ins
you probably get to it from somewhere
inside the house
why would I want to I don't know what
the hell just happened okay
one of the unique advantages though that
emulating this game does afford is that
you guys get to see it in a higher
resolution which means that you do enjoy
more of what was meant to be enjoyed in
the game because the original resolution
is always 6:40 you're watching it now at
nine twenty by ten eighty I hoped he'd
sixty frames per second hopefully that's
gonna be some quality here I mean some
people say this is the scariest game
that they've ever played and probably
ghosts I've been saying goes for a while
now
what's wrong
I don't want to kill you
okay you know normal system normal
sister bonding stuff holy crap
god the sounds of this game is amazing
I mean what they lacked in graphical
fidelity they must have make up for in
audio engineering which is a good
component in organs I always tout the
importance of audio in organs like two
inches from me stop being such a big
baby oh I'm sorry
oh my anyway oh I apologize excuse me
Jojo Jojo was pretty damn good judge it
was like the best cop I ever knew not
that worktops at all we're like I don't
even know 14 girls we're probably like
three tween girls I've heard rumors
about the lost village before long ago a
masker occurred on the day of my
ceremony and the village was wiped from
the map
quinton day these statues in the forest
lead lost people to the building's
entrance when she passed through the
gate however cannot go back the village
eternally reserves that night of death
the insane laughter of a woman is said
to echo throughout the village the only
survivor of the massacre at the village
was alone holder of the insane laughter
of a woman and the lone survivor woman
are in any way connected top it probably
ab probably not and then again I'm just
a ghost expert also I'm very excited to
be able to start a long let's play again
for you guys and I think I think this is
really going to be a fun choice for you
guys because I've already into it like
I'm already down to clown I can't
possibly imagine me being more down to
clown than I am right now
anyway alright so okay so obviously I
can't choose the camera angles that I
play with I mean this is something that
came out of early Resident Evil styled
gaming and kind of expanded onto other
certain styles it until they learned
that being able to control the cameras
very cool however this comes after many
of those games have ever existed so I
think it's more stylistic choice for the
art
the game than anything else these low
angle shots aren't creepy at all okay I
know I'm just gonna like transition one
scene and like it's not gonna be my you
following me it's going to be some
creepy ghosty there's a padlock engraved
with a family crest representing ginger
on the door
oh the ginger family those redheaded
y'all right there my yoke yes who's here
who's nearby you my you okay so far I
haven't noticed any bugs happening with
the rendering on emulation my are you
just gonna okay see I don't know what to
expect from this my you you just calm
down until I can figure this out stop
being a little bit too crazy
so where are we going oh I just went
backwards I went in a big loop okay so I
need to find a key now again with this
game a lot of people warned me that
there was going to be a lot of puzzle
solving and I might get lost and stuck
and circling around a bit but I don't
intend to show you guys any of that like
directly to your face I want you guys to
enjoy this as much as I do and that
means cutting out of bed parts so
whenever I get stuck don't you worry
I'm gonna make sure that you don't have
to watch me flailing around like an
idiot unless it's really really funny
okay so I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna
explore a bit BRB oh here we go
found something okay what's this it's
nothing is that oh oh it's a thing
okay where the hell am i oh there's no
book sometimes I sent someone passing by
the window he cares it torts and mutters
things he seems to be searching for
somebody but it's not musubi
in the distance I can hear some kind of
sad ceremonial song being sung
they say that this village vanished on
the day of a ceremony and that day is
repeated over and over again well why
would you know that it vanished if
you're right there in the middle of the
village as it's vanishing unless you're
just reliving and you don't know it yet
okay you need to stop saying so many
creepy things because I'm not having
none of it
I want to just get by not being
confronted Oh sacred water oh that's
really important good for me
okay what's this so are all are all of
these rooms that I need to go into or
okay that's creepy way to enter a room
someone's saying why there's nobody no
even notebook for someone anyone whoever
sees this look for me I'm trapped in
this village help me it seems to be a
body under this huh it's a lump in it as
if something's inside don't investigate
okay flying nor of a closet won't open
anymore
hanging pain but it's so faded you can't
even see the color of the flowers so
there was another room right next to his
I'm gonna go in that one because I
obviously got notebook for I'm supposed
to have notebook three I keep forgetting
that that's not actually a loading
screen or anything no not that one you
ding-dong you're supposed to go find
another one I'm thinking there might
have been another one upstairs I just
didn't think it was any different from a
wall because I'm not used to that stuff
god damn in mocking you that was
creepiest creaking I've ever heard kept
searching for who who huh I don't think
I've been back here yeah let me go run
toward the ghost full steam okay that
looks like the ginger symbol so maybe
I'm gonna meet the ginger family and be
able to get there because ghosts because
ghosts everywhere huh sorry for my
outburst but need to address certain
issues woman's not book three okay
Masumi it's me Miyako I came to look for
you let's go home together together we
can make it call for me if you find this
I'll be nearby miss you even though I'm
lost in a village alone but the ghosts
are all the ghosts okay so am I supposed
to go outside I'm assuming yes there's
some murky water in the wash basin I'm
sorry if I'm not reading those I'm kind
of just glancing by really quickly I
shouldn't because that's gonna get me in
trouble
excuse me sorry bye bye you know I don't
get down there I want to go in the
quarry oh oh okay I want to go in the
courtyard courtyard courtyard lanterns
are at the back of the garden they're
lit cool damp wind is blowing in from
the atrium okay so I guess I can't go
through there so what good did this do
me wait the plaster has come loose
because of the moisture from outside
okay hasn't been used in a long time so
what's the point of all of this I mean
this had the crest of the ginger family
I was only assuming there would be some
ginger family people in here you didn't
see the room on the other side through
the cracks between the sliding doors
okay sorry so am I supposed to go find
the other one possibly I know that door
opening is sleeping up for bad stuff to
happen the door is slightly ajar okay
god it's hard to tell it's actually a
door around here I mean yeah that sounds
me right he's actually pretty why you
you need to stop saying so creepy things
it's making me concerned and paranoid
there's a flashlight on the table that's
good
seems like the batteries are still good
someone must have left it here okay an
old book is under the flashlights camera
pointers is written on the cover okay
this camera was made by dr. a so to take
photographs of beings in the spiritual
plane that normally cannot be seen can
reveal events from the past through the
lingering thoughts of individuals is
also able to photograph spiritual beings
that are invisible to the human eye
taking a photo of an unseen being has an
exorcism effect but simultaneously
creates a sort of linked with them the
camera obscura is used carelessly these
beings may even gain the upper hand on
the user I wonder if I can photograph
the site at the heart of this village
village is forbidden ritual if dr. a so
we're here I'm sure he would be excited
okay it's much older than the flashlight
so that's what I need to find I need to
find the camera obscura
to be able to do what I need to do oh is
that it is that what I needed
oh good it's only a few feet from me
then I don't need to go very far to find
it
oh well you did just drop it on the
ground and probably broke it
I can't believe well it's true I guess
why do you keep touching things that you
really weird flashbacks
here's someone here know
you mean the floorboards
okay what we're not gonna do anything
about that basic camera operation the
camera obscura is the special camera
that allows you to exercise spirits by
taking photographs of them because it
steals your soul when you face a
direction where the Spirit is the
filming at the bottom right of the
screen or the top of the viewfinder will
glow once you've located spirit raise
the camera with the circle button when
you found in spirits enter it in the
viewfinder and press the shutter button
to take a photo of it okay
tutorial files were saved in the scrap
on the menu okay so I got the full
rundown on how to use this I'm gonna be
perfect look at the camera there's
something on the other side of that wall
doing much careful I sure I'm glad that
this camera is pointed away from it
surely advantageous to my survival okay
what is that over there
just something I need that wasn't there
before at least I can finally see into
the darkness
either withered something on the floor
herbal medicine okay smaller screens
okay then get out of my way me you we
got problems we got a whole bunch of
problems yes so many problems looks like
they won't be able to get through
they're broken in won't budge okay wait
where'd that other one say cold air
blows in between the cracks okay like
having heard that one before okay so
let's see what this ghosty goo is gonna
do to me so in there yeah just go
face-first into it
I see it I see it what do I do
Kabam doorwoman did I do it I did it
come on let's get out of here
I feel like this whole playthroughs just
been me making this face like what the
hell is going on you the presence you
were feeling in front of the door is
gone now it said you can capture things
that ordinary people can't see with his
camera could this be the power of the
camera obscura I saw a lady staring at
me in the face with my own two eyes what
are you talking about I knew there ain't
gonna tell me it wasn't okay so now that
we got the camera we can finally start
to make a little bit of progress around
here and we have a flashlight which
means that we're gonna be able to see in
the dark which is going to help us okay
so I'm assuming that if I go back here I
can find the gym gear family members and
steal their souls and get them to tell
me god damn it's just muse
they're gonna tell me where to find the
key for the padlock which means that I'm
gonna be able to progress which is what
I need to do I'm not running right now
because I know one run smack-dab into
anything bad cuz I've done that many
times before I'm gonna play this game
very seriously while I do a pirouette in
the middle of this room this is how your
exercise goes to everybody you just
start spinning and then I'm gonna take
the game seriously like right now right
now it's good
The Doors held shut by some kind of
powerful force what does that even mean
you see my oh hey I'm gonna camera
obscure the [ __ ] out of their ghost
that's a look alright oh no come back
here I just want to film you a bit way
being so camera che it's really hard
because they reverse the directions of
this goddamn thing okay so that's how
you want to play it huh oh yeah I know
you're in there I'll just take a quick
snap the different place shows what does
that even mean how does that happen
looks like a coal brazier somewhere I
know where that is so I need to go to
there you put the coal brazier photo in
your file so I need to go to the area
where there was a coal brazier and then
they need to come around back so I can
open that door and take a boat you're a
poacher
what does put my birds I'll take a
picture of the ghosty goo inside there
and there's cold brazier in this back
room over here because of the cold
draught brought in by the wind Liz I'm
totally rocking him totally backwards
but I think it was back here if not it
was somewhere else yes ghost that be
who's over there who's buying the coal
brazier
okay I don't see anything well how do
you see something shows in the photo
looks like an injured man looks like an
injured man trying to kill someone
oh okay then bye have fun
nightmare land I'll be visiting you
don't look good so uh what the hell was
that I'm assuming the door on the or the
lock on the door in the other room is
open now so that I can probably go
through there and then confront the
ghosts in there I know it's gonna get
hard just yet because it's obviously in
the beginning stages of this and I'm
still learning but I'm learning quickly
and I'm learning efficiently and I
haven't died yet which is basically
better than I ever do in most of these
games now what's interesting is that
this game it's not gonna feature any
combat the only comment is gonna be me
taking photos of people which doesn't
seem very combative but hey I'm gonna be
competitive and I'm gonna be very very
good at it
now I should be able to be able to go
over here going here wolf deer go
through here it's open so open it and
then go see the lump on the floor
because that's where I went before lumpy
hey wake up lumpy hey lumpy lumpy lumpy
lumpy wait so the doors is gonna be open
now but you're not gonna give me
anything for it
well yeah Donna may get all the way me
you wait well then what was the point of
coming in here had to be something else
looks like an atrium it's either deck
beyond the atrium well I know about that
deck but I was just there this is game
one for me okay when I first came here
it was supposed to mislead me and think
that there was nothing here my use
you're gonna kick in my way a lot aren't
you I'm gonna like you Justin hey I got
the ginger key me really I doubt that
very much so why did you miss me are you
the lady that's leaving all these
journals I shouldn't leave your personal
items I got you scare climber
well another picture huh that's right
you run away I'm lightning fast with his
camera obscura at the front door just
disappeared something is there a front
door over here oh no this is the back
entrance to it I'm okay
okay I'm coming for you I'm coming for
you stair climber I got the ginger key
ah just too slow all right
we'll lock the door with the ginger key
okay thank you I apologize it's very
easy to skip things like dialog God my
oh you are creepy
why are you so creepy God you're backing
her you ain't gonna beckon me
oh no the cameras look at that no creepy
that is it's not being so creepy my you
be less creepy I'm of course not telling
her about any of the ghosts that I'm
encountering right now dammit
god I'm sorry the surface of the folding
screen has come loose and is falling off
got that wasn't what it said before
being it I'm sorry guys I'm trying I'm
not trying to make things go by really
quickly I'm just trying to make sure I
use everything and now I'm miss paid six
okay how much time has passed since I
came here how long will this night last
I can't take the darkness it's driving
me crazy I have to get out of here
I have to see Masumi okay fine I'm
assuming you are the beckoner which
means they're probably gonna try to kill
yourself
I must be tired if I start to relax I
pass out even in a crazy place like this
the darkness here is creeping into my
dreams slaughter rivers of blood fallen
people a woman in a blood-stained kimono
insane laughter and twin sisters calling
out don't kill me
that woman's life to sear it into my
mind I don't want to sleep in think
you're doing come on I didn't want to
take a picture of you not that you're
not beautiful but come on okay Masumi
found my note he was in the village I
can see him soon I can't move I'll wait
here
he'll be back he'll find the way out if
he comes back which he might not he came
so many jokes so little time okay he
came the last part of the memo stops
abruptly doesn't sound like he came with
goodwill he also came
he came into the house looking for her
boyfriend and then where did she go
can you picture last longer than your
life okay BAM capturing exercising
spirits okay perfect time for a tutorial
you can exorcise spears by taking
photographs of them with the camera
scare the greater the response indicated
on the charge gate in the capture circle
the greatest damage you can flicked on
the spear the charge gate glow thread
that instant is a shudder chance you can
shoot during this instant you can
inflict heavier damage on the spirit and
repel back further okay there will be
combat all right using this blast back
ability will push it back
approaching spear you must have failed
to shoot and shooting in succession you
have to wait for the next shot to look
before shooting again while loading
pressing the shutter button will have no
effect high-power film gives more damage
and loads quicker
of course it dies cuz it's like bullets
film bullets okay here we go
I'm gonna get you weren't there
we were we weren't artists - Detroit
Milwaukee miss whoo yes whoo huh
goddamn it goddamn controls
son-of-a-bitch controls stop rattling
with her yeah I did it won the money is
Bato how's it going over there
how's it going weepy sob story yo hey
Sonny Tim do it why don't we keep going
over there she's not over there is he
maybe she no no no no no gonna get you
gonna get you oh give me a give me a big
smile give me a big come on
there
oh no you solving Sumi
oh hey hey hey no no no no give me give
me give me a good one
damn it come on it's more complicated
than I thought it was
are you sticking with your hands out
I got like peanut butter I look at the
butt cheek those sticking out of the
wall
Hey okay good job good job
yes very good shot huh paparazzi up in
this [ __ ] I'm gonna move yo I did my
first ghost
oh no okay I passed out for some reason
okay so the poor lady her boyfriend
finally came but her boyfriend wasn't
exactly herself so she kind of got Nam
Don which is not exactly good a rugged
knight aragonite looks like a glowing
blue crystal that spirit must have
dropped it once you find the spirit
stone radio you can use the radio on the
menu to listen to the stones spirit orb
acquired spirit orb are items used to
rave maximum level of the cameras basic
functions and powerup lenses use a
spirit or from the function upgrades on
the camera menu to increase the maximum
level of liquid funds power okay after
adding a spirit orb to one of these
camera basic functions of power I
blenders you can raise his level by
using the points you've accumulated
through capture spirits okay then that's
all very important information about
upgrading my camera that I'm certain to
use oh it's right there you just told me
about a little bit ago alright then
okay spirit zone radio Oh more reading
okay through the use of crystals in the
circuits this improved version of a
crystal radio was able to tune into
voices from the spirit world
cuz I'm a crazy person if a person wears
crystal for a long time their thoughts
will remain within creating special type
of crystal of spirits according to dr. a
so the radio can be picked up sound from
the spirit world indicating feelings and
intuitions in similar manner it is a
sympathetic phenomenon that occurs
between please ah because that's
important because the twins are a theme
that have been referenced to before
because twins were mentioned imagine
that we me you and my you my oh and me
my oh and me and my you is gone so I
think that's probably a bit of a bad
I'm not sure exactly anyway let's keep
trucking along we just crossed into
chapter 2 which I'm assuming is just a
celebratory thing after beating my first
boss I'm assuming that probably some
other thing around here maybe not
I would imagine I would be a bit more
concerned about losing my you but hey at
least she's not gonna get in my way
anymore where the hell let me go oh yeah
this room was much bigger than I thought
it was so it's gonna dance around for a
little bit before I finally find my way
out of here it's weird because when the
camera transitions it likes to stick you
in the direction it's going which is
kind of convenient because it does
change a lot what doesn't make a goddamn
bit of sense you get back here sister of
mine the butterflies
Oh Oh I'm playing I didn't even know
that I was playing what the hell is that
oh no no I can't go that way invisible
wall sorry I'm supposed to follow the
crimson butterflies and I had no damn
idea oh not that way either sorry I
didn't know what's coming what's
happening I'm on my way
crimson butterflies I'm not hopped up on
mas village drugs who are you who are
you okay so were you just having a link
between your twin sister I still don't
know what the hell is going on in this
game but I have a little bit of a better
idea than I did before at least you
found some camera equipment and film
wired the slow power of plans
okay effects slows down the movement of
a spirit spirit power required one
extends duration okay press triangle and
you've charged one or more spirit power
please
well this effective active the sphere
will move slower and shudder trances
will be longer okey-dokey then that's
all very good and it's upgradable which
means that gek can help me out more
sounds of camera equipment infill
measure equipment okay shows spirit HP
that's good very good remaining HP of
the closest spirit okay
sounds good to me I'm all down for this
I'm swimming that I'm gonna be
encountering a lot more spirits in the
very near future whoa what the [ __ ] yeah
here why don't you creepy bastard
bastard
Oh weirdo what is going on here suddenly
happen oh no that's what I thought
just kill I killed him and killed him
just dead the hell how did this all just
happen this couldn't have just been oh
they were here the whole time
charged up Danielle yeah that's good
picture oh god don't touch me with your
grubby ghost hands I don't want none of
it how about that you like that that's
good it's good shot mister how about now
and that's your good side I like
oh god this isn't doing anything to him
come on supposed to be a famil
maybe I gotta charge the meter like all
the all the way up to be able to do
anything that's how you do it I got the
let him get really really creepily close
to me before it actually do anything
okay was there another one in here oh no
they're all gone okay I did it oh this
is ridiculous but awesome I love it oh
man by the way I'm gonna try to keep
these episodes to about 45 minutes to an
hour it all depends on how much I play
because I am gonna be I use charm okay
because I am gonna be like cutting out a
bit to try to make this a bit more easy
to watch because I don't want you to
watch me flicking so like how long the
episode depends entirely on how much I
have failed so that's a good measure
okay I saw another object in this room
over here so I'm just gonna get this
real quick save and I'll be good early
twirly there and that camera is not as
easy as I thought it was going well
thank you hey okay this isn't a time for
this go away please
god damn it you son of a [ __ ] oh that
is disturbing oh that is that is very
clean
oh god damn it that was my chance
goddamn in No so what I wanted
go down no those triangles with that
gotcha gotcha baby oh that guy
oh closely run up in my grill oh now I
see you see oh that did it okay
somehow that did it freakin hairy weirdo
damn it you're not doing it no no good
deed the face all right I guess gonna
happen it's hard to control it's gonna
take a lot of getting easy don't be
charging your grubby hands and made
everybody I did it now I can say even be
proud of what I've done
god this game is a great mix of creepy
and I don't know what the hell is
happening which is a fantastic place to
be for me
really okay so that is the beginning of
fatal frame I really really really hope
you guys are enjoying this I want to
know everything that you think about
this game I know a lot of people have
played it treat please try to keep the
comments as spoiler free as possible
just because a lot of people this may be
their first time playing the game me so
I am really happy about this but please
please let me know what you think of
this game in the comments below I'm
going to play this game from start to
finish because there's only been good
things said about this and I promised
for a long time than I'm gonna play this
game I really hope you guys are enjoying
it thank you everybody so much for
watching feel free to give me tips below
but I may be recording in multiple
sessions at once thanks again everybody
and as always I can see you